I am here at the University of Sydney where the mechanical engineering shop...
...has built this incredible piece of apparatus for me.
It is a 40-pound, that is 19-kilogram, flywheel on the end of a meter-long shaft.
Can you imagine trying to hold this out horizontally with just one hand at this end?
It is virtually... It is impossible, okay?
Let's prove that I could lift it, just this end, without it spinning.
Here we go.
I mean, it's just kind of awkward with the hand.
Careful!
Just barely.
Oh goodness, do you even lift?
Clearly I do not.
Undaunted by my lack of strength, I'm going for it.
But I want to make sure that the wheel is spinning as fast as possible...
...to give me the best chance of success.
Now, I am going to release my left hand...
...and, holding only with my right hand at the end of the shaft,...
...I'll try to lift it up over my head.
This is a 40-pound, 19-kilogram flywheel.
Ready?
Here we go: three, two, one.
Beautiful!